I feel like society today,
especially millennials were addicted to feeling sensitive and offended.
Like literally people's nipples get hard when they're freaking offended by
something.
With the election. Upon us,
millions of Americans are gearing up to cast their vote for the next president
of the United States. While some people will be voting independent.
We want it to hear from Trump voters and biting voters about why they are voting
for their candidate in spectrum.
We bring everyday people together for authentic discussions that represent
what's happening. Now,
these discussions should not be anyone sole source forming opinions on important
issues. Please do your own research, seek out experts,
push yourself outside your bubble and have empathy. Thanks for watching.
Hello, my name is Rachel I'm from Dallas, Texas.
I've been a conservative my whole life,
but my views have definitely evolved and I'm happy to be here. Hi, I'm Casey.
I live in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
and I actually work in politics and I've watched very closely,
kind of the Republican party turned from republicanism to kind of Trump
republicanism. And I'm excited to talk about that.
Hi, my name is Noah. I'm a teenage conservative from the great state of Georgia.
Uh, I've been a conservative for my whole life and I'm really looking forward to
this discussion. My name is Malique I'm from Detroit, Michigan.
I just turned 23. I was always economical. Even when I was very little.
Now I'm a medical student in the theater.
Hi, my name is Amie when it comes to social issues and everything, I, uh,
could be considered a little bit more liberal.
I do support our president 100%, four more years was good.
So yeah.
Hi, my name's Alicia. I'm 20 years old.
My mom immigrated to America from Nicaragua as a political refugee.
And then my father's side of the family immigrated from Mexico and I am also
eight months pregnant and I'm super excited to be a first time. Mom.
Behavior can be offensive. Rachel,
somewhat disagree. Casey agree.
Noah agree, army.
Alicia, strongly agree. Agree.
I think that Trump gets a lot of flack more than other presidents for
offending people because he is not politically correct.
The politically correct culture has been shoved down our throats.
And the reason why people like his rhetoric is because he doesn't put
up with that toxic culture.
The reason I said agree is because while he hasn't directly offended me,
I do think some of the, some of his rhetoric can be offensive. I mean,
I I'm sure stormy Daniels was pretty offended to be called Horseface even though
it was Epic. When it comes to a lot of his policies, I tend to agree with him,
uh, what he, what he's done with the taxes. I think we can all agree. Well,
if we could just take his Twitter account away,
sometimes I just limit what he says.
You're going to get a good writer in their first tweets.
I think we'd be in a way better place in the country.
I actually enjoy president Trump's tweets. I have at least been set up.
I agree with me. I don't even factor.
In the rhetoric, but when it comes to president Trump anymore,
because of all the results that he's gotten and if that's how he has to behave
in order to achieve the results, I'm totally fine for it.
I see a fighter and that's what I like about him.
The one time he offended me, I quickly found out that it was from fake news.
So that was in the beginning of the election when he was running in 2016. Um,
it was the disabled thing. Like the little girl,
that little thing that offended me,
but that quickly dissipated when I found out that's what he does.
Everything else that I have heard him say from this point, um,
I haven't felt personally offended, but when I hear him say certain things,
I'm like, I could hear the screeching. I could hear it.
Re you can just hear like the freaking people freaking out.
Yeah.
The one thing that I say kind of offended me that I kind of didn't like was when
he, the Hollywood access tape grabbed him by the, you know,
I didn't really like that. But then, um,
I thought about it more about he wasn't running for president.
He was a Democrat at the time. Uh,
and this has nothing to do with who he is today. He was talking about groupies.
And to me, like when I asked, looked at the context and everything like, yeah,
now, now I know who he's talking about. He's not talking about, Oh, army.
I could just grab, no, you can't do that to be able to do that.
I'm going to hit you with a backhand over there.
Exactly what he's talking about. The women that are like, not just any woman,
he was particular women.
And think of when he said that stuff to and access Hollywood, by that time,
Donald Trump was being talked about in rap videos.
He was on comedy central during those rails, he was in Hollywood.
We know who he was talking about. So when all these people,
especially in the black community, when you dare you, the grab them by the foot.
If he had been black and said it in a rap song
[inaudible] Oh, wait, wait, wait, he's a Republican. Oh no, no, no. We disagree.
We disagree.
Yeah. I was only ever offended by Trump once.
And this was whenever he said something about like Mexicans being like animals
or like something like that. And so I was like, Oh my gosh, it's so offensive.
Like, why would he say that? And then my stepdad was like,
did you read like everything that he said?
So I went back and he was talking about like the Ms. 13 gangs that were in
Mexico and stuff. So I like,
kind of learned a lot about fake news and how a lot of people are like
sensitive to his rhetoric and what he says.
What do you think? I feel like society today,
especially millennials were addicted to feeling sensitive and offended.
Like literally people's nipples get hard when they're freaking offended by
something.
I mean, I mean, I, I think I know why that is. It's because if I'm offended,
if I'm a victim, I get more attention. It's like,
there's a hierarchy of victimhood. Well, I'm black,
but you're black army and a woman. So that means you get more power.
It's like in the lips, it's like the more victimized you are,
the more you should be heard, the more power you should be given. And to me,
I think that's pretty sad. Systemic racism.
That's a problem in America,
strongly disagree, somewhat disagree.
Noah. I said, somewhat agree, somewhat agree.
I said, strongly disagree, fully.
Somewhat agree.
Systemic implies that it's built into the DNA of our country.
And I just don't think that that was why this country was founded.
It wasn't founded to be a racist.
Systemic is really that there's laws in place that
prevent people of color from excelling. And while in the past,
there definitely have been laws that were systemically racist.
There aren't any anymore. There's so many examples,
people of color that Excel in America, for example, like Barack Obama,
he's like a black president.
You also have like AOC who was a bartender. She's a person of color.
And she literally just like came up and became like, you know,
house of representative.
Can I ask everybody this real quick,
Joe Biden's 94 crime bill that specifically targeted people of color.
You wouldn't consider that to be systematic.
Something that was put into place that is going to target the breakdown. One,
the break down of the fan black family. Sorry to be like a military,
but there's some skid marks. America has some like total skin marks.
Yeah. There has been like,
cause like I'm studying history and I'm taking an old South class.
So we're just talking about slavery. Like,
so I'm not denying that there hasn't been systemic slavery before,
but I in 2020 today, like there's not systemic racism.
In the nineties 94. That was the year I was born. That's no, not too long ago.
And the residue, the effects that I had within two generations, um, is,
you know, it looked pretty structured to me. You know what I mean?
Like what you had to say with, um, the 1994 crime bill,
because that's exactly where I was going with it. That's why I somewhat agree.
And the other policy,
that thing is also really important would be school choice in the schools that
were,
I was growing up the way they teach history and the way they teach the spirit,
you know, that they were teaching.
Well, I felt like in the classroom.
You are determined that you will fail. You cannot succeed.
You will never make it. And to me personally,
whenever somebody told me I can't do something, I said, okay, watch.
And then I went to medical school, but, uh, for a lot of other people,
they don't have what I have, you know?
So I think it is systematic because it's mostly black people in these areas
being caught,
these things that keep them from even thinking that it's possible for them to
achieve. So that's why I say systematic racism is a problem.
And it comes from the democratic side.
I have to disagree. There's no law saying that you have to teach black children,
that they can't make it in the world. The issue is really funding.
And I think people get distracted and tend to blame it on system,
on systemic racism. When it's not a, it's a poverty issue.
You don't think that systematically white kids are in poor districts as well.
And there are tons of districts around the nation who that are a majority white
and they're poor, but black people are typically, if we look at statistics,
black people are in that lower income.
People of color are in that lower income bubble right there.
I feel like that's systematic. You know what I mean?
It's targeting a specific group.
There are tons of white kids in that bubble too. No, I didn't. I didn't. Yeah,
I didn't dis I didn't, uh, disagree on that part. I definitely,
Brian gave a shout out to, you know, there are white kids in the trailer park.
A lot of it has to do with like the culture or the way that the
black like normal, typical black family is set up. The statistics say that, uh,
black people don't have like two family households and that has a lot to do.
Yeah. That has like a lot to do with like, Oh, the poverty rates there,
like where they end up in school, they go to jail more often.
So I don't think it's systemic racism and like more as the,
that it's a fact of having to like educate.
A lot to deal with race in this country. I'll tell my friends on the left.
They literally just see it, that it is a racist country.
We're never not going to be.
And we need like insane change to
just blow up the system. I think that that,
that would be the most foolish thing.
When you look at who's helping the black community, uh,
I think the president Trump has done a ton for the black community more than
under Emmy, more than under Barack Obama. That's for sure.
I believe COVID 19 is a serious and real disease.
Rachel disagree. Casey. I strongly agree,
Noah. I somewhat agree. Amy
Alicia.
Somewhat agree.
I mean, anything that can cause the death of somebody is serious.
I can strongly agree with that statement while at the same time being against a
lot of the measures that have been taking place,
especially over an extended period of time, it's affected my mental health.
And I have a lot of people who are scared to kind of speak out,
but of course the disease itself. Yes, it's real. Yes. It's serious.
I've known people who have family members who have passed away,
but what if I don't believe it's to the degree that the media made it out to be?
I mean,
they said really early on 2 million people will die and we're at 200,000 overall
it's most likely been inflated a lot and is a really interesting question for me
because I'm in medical school, I have access to information.
I like the general public doesn't.
So the thing I would say is context is not being given to the
general public. I noticed one a week. There was like, Oh my God,
there's been a surge in this state. Well, I know I drive through, uh,
just opened. Was there really a third in cases?
Or was there a third and testing?
I think that we are being distracted by the real problem in America.
And the real problem in America is we're not healthy.
Overall. We're one of the sickest countries who is a first world country.
So I think the media has really blown it out of proportion. Um,
I don't think it's as serious as it's made out to be it's being politicized.
Um, and I don't know if you guys remember in the very beginning when they talked
about this COVID they said that the African-American community was actually,
uh, you know,
more prone to getting the COVID or the Chinese virus got to say it guys going to
say Chinese virus.
And it makes sense if we want to look at the black community specifically,
when it comes to high blood pressure, heart disease, diabetes,
we got to take that in consideration.
And unfortunately we can't really compare ourselves to Sweden.
You can't really compare ourselves to these other countries,
that one have a smaller population and also with healthier lifestyles than we do
as Americans.
I am open to liberal ideas,
Rachel,
a great Casey great Noah.
I strongly agree. Totally agree. Elisia.
I said agree.
I totally agree.
So I said agree,
but like right now they're just like portraying so many radical views
that it's like shutting me down from like listening to them entirely like
socialism. That's like the number one for me,
because I know that socialism leads to communism and people cannot tell me
otherwise.
And like my family actually like left Nicaragua because of like the
socialist, like stuff and the communism that was happening. So,
and I know a lot of Hispanic people, like,
that's probably why Joe Biden isn't getting like any,
that much support he is getting support, but not that much support him.
Super conservative, but I'm also an urbanist. And I don't mind, uh,
live in a city I'm totally open to it and even apply some, I mean, I'm,
I'm almost vegan. So I had to say that because I'm almost there yet,
but you know,
it's okay for conservatives to care about the environment and things like that.
Something that you would consider liberal.
I especially liked listening to Andrew Yang.
I it's hard to hate that guy and you just can't. Um, but I, I,
nothing about Joe Biden interests me. My biggest voting issue of all is China.
And I think that it is the common Chinese communist party is the biggest threat
to the global order, but especially the American way.
And Joe Biden has made it very clear that he's,
he's really not going to do too much to handle them.
And in the past has actually enabled them.
Very, very open to having discussions with literally everybody. Um,
I'm in Brexit and down here in our Tennessee chapter,
when we are come across black lives matter,
we cross over the street and we talk to them friendly, peacefully,
great conversation. We find a ton of middle ground.
We had each other on freaking Facebook, but I feel like leftist today.
She just be open and honest and just call themselves Marxist because there's
literally no, pretty much no difference. Now these days, when it looks at,
when you look at Bernie Sanders, when you look at black lives matter,
and then let's add in a bunch of like illegal immigrants,
when we can even take in our own take care of our own people, there's no logic,
there's no logic to it.
I'm open to talking and adopting things like who you decide to marry and all
that kind of stuff. I'm open to that.
Give people equal opportunity to succeed.
But if you want to look at the LGBTQ stuff for you as an adult,
talking to another adult and consenting to do whatever you do,
but I'm not for is shoving it down. Children's throats. I'm a mom of three.
I don't play that. No. What do you need to talk about to my kids about your, um,
being willing Steph and what you decide to identity?
We don't care if they want to play with the toys.
Uh, well I work for the gay Republican group. Uh, so I am,
uh, their political director in Pennsylvania and Ohio. And, uh, as far as,
as far as gay issues go,
I think that people looking to pass gay marriage or like repeal gamer,
I think that's big government.
I think the government shouldn't decide what is defined as marriage at all.
Donald Trump has stood for the gays and gay marriage
for a lot longer than Joe Biden has Joe Biden and enter the 2012
presidential campaigns still opposing gay marriage.
And so if we're going to talk about that issue,
then I feel like public opinion has come around on that. I said,
I strongly agree because the high school I graduated from,
I was able to graduate with a kid who I believe he worked on Bernie Sanders
campaign at some point.
And I've been able to talk to them frequently since we graduated.
We've had a lot of discussions and we have to understand there's not liberal
problems and conservative problems. There's American problems that we all have.
We just have to, we all have the same end goal.
We just have two different ways to get there. We all want America to be better.
At least I hope we do. I try to,
I try to say what if I'm wrong and what if they're right.
So I can truly see what they think.
America is better now than it was four years ago.
Rachel strongly agree. Casey.
I strongly agree, Noah. I strongly agree.
AMI Elysium,
strongly agree. Strongly agree.
Yeah. So I put, I somewhat agree and that kind of actually sucks to say,
cause I, I wish it was strongly agree, but when, in terms of race relations, um,
I feel like I'm taking so many steps backwards.
I never thought that as a millennial and somebody in 2020,
that I would go outside my door and there would be like tension friends. Um,
just so many each other family disowning, each other. Um,
I know I'm experiencing, I've experienced that. I think we have come a long way,
but when it comes to racial matters and stuff,
unfortunately I think we've taken some steps back.
I believe all problems are downstream of economics.
And I think when Trump says,
we're going to do opportunities on is we're going to invest in billions and
billions of dollars into low income areas. But in Detroit,
the gentrification that happened,
which I'm a big supporter of it gave specific family.
Members and my family jobs that paid like four times what they were making
before. And that's because of Didion.
They're now on like one third of downtown Detroit people complain about it.
But before I bet one third of these buildings were abandoned.
That's done more for the black community than any president I've known in my
lifetime. I feel the tension that, um, he feels, um,
but I do feel like president Trump's the leader to lead us out of that because I
see the Democrat party, they see the pain,
they use it. People who are hurting,
make them hurt a little bit more and become victims to whatever hurt they have,
whether it's racial or otherwise. And I don't, I don't appreciate that.
And I don't think that that's the answer.
I think president Trump's optimism is the answer to the healing that I really
do.
I do think that the economy is the biggest thing and probably the only thing
that president Trump can do for us when it comes to race relations.
I don't personally think that Trump is the answer to race relations because
that's a bigger discussion as beyond Trump.
The best thing that president Trump can do for black America and people of color
is to just give them the opportunity to thrive.
And I think he's done that great job at that. Especially, you know,
before the China virus took place and everything. Um,
but when it comes to race relations, the media has such a massive part to play.
And I think a first step that we could do as society is hold our mainstream
media accountable.
If we didn't have to dig to see that Trump has denounced white supremacy
multiple times,
and the mainstream was doing their jobs and not adding fuel to the fire. Um,
I think maybe as a society, we could all come together and,
and hold the media accountable for the attention that they have caused when it
comes to race relations. I don't think it has anything to do with.
America has always had political polarization. We've always had racial issues,
but at least we have these problems and we have a robust economy, you know,
in January and February and March,
once Donald Trump gives a second inaugural address,
we'll see the economy bounce right back.
He's not the president in order to gain power.
When COVID happens,
he did not use the opportunity to assert more power than he already
had. It really concerns me when politicians like Joe Biden say,
he's going to make the entire country follow a mandatory mask mandate.
That's completely unacceptable. It's an overreach of power.
I think a lot of why America is so strong is because we have such a
strong leader like president Trump and he cares.
He genuinely cares about America.
He loves America so much and he also loves the American people.
So I think it's like super nice to just see that, um,
a president who is enthusiastic to work for this beautiful
country that I love and the American people, which is like you and me.
So on that note, you guys, that is a wrap, great job,
everyone. Bye-bye.